464-3080
as the debate on tax legislation heats
up in washington d.c
encore book notes dips into its archives
for historical perspective charles adams
is a taxation law specialist and
independent scholar at the cato
institute a think tank in washington dc
in march of 1993 he appeared on book
notes to discuss for good and evil the
impact of taxes on the course of
civilization
in it he examines the various aspects of
taxation policies around the world
this program is about an hour
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
this week our guest is tax specialist
charles adams he joins us to discuss his
recent book for good and evil the impact
of taxes on the course of civilization
[Music]
charles adams author of for good and
evil the impact of taxes on the course
of civilization
where does the word tax come from
it means to exact
who invented it
i think taxes were invented before we
learned how to write there's there's no
known civilization that didn't tax
and taxes are as old as the recorded
history in fact some of the earliest
recorded history we have
uh makes us realize that uh well many
things have changed in history
that taxpayers and tax collectors really
haven't changed very much in 5 000 years
you have a favorite tax collector in
history
probably the favorite is when we don't
know they're they're on the hill of the
acropolis uh in athens there's a a
marble
uh uh
writing there that is in honor of the
honest tax collector and whoever that
fellow was is probably my favorite tag
collector although i think that maybe
aristides would be the most famous tax
collector he was the athenian general
and he was appointed
at the time that the persians were about
to attack the
greeks and try to impose taxes upon the
greek city-states
so uh the great city-states of sparta
and athens formed a league they they
called it the eventually was called the
athenian league and all of the cities
and there were maybe as many as 200
cities in that
city-states that were in athens area
they got together and they had a nato
type arrangement and they had nato
commanders and they had a common tax and
the tax was collected by aristides
and we we read in ancient history that
this was a golden age for the allies of
greece because of aristide he's the just
so he may be the father of just taxation
i think he'd be my favorite i read i
think in the back did you live in
toronto yes yes you pay more tax in
toronto than you would if you live in
the united states yes
why do you live there
well i lived there because i married a
canadian i suppose that that's the
answer and your wife always makes you
over but she took me back to canada and
i i fell in love with canada and i'm
happy to live there but i'm still
basically a native son of america how
much more do they pay in tax than we do
here i would say about the same
the taxes come in different directions
up there they have some exemptions that
we don't have here and
but uh i think that uh the numbers are
are maybe one or two percent more i've
seen them like i i think that just one
or two percent more
why'd you write the book
i wrote the book because i felt that
i i had a message
i felt i had peculiar qualifications for
the book
besides the fact that i love history and
i started out to be a history teacher
i discovered that
as a as a assistant professor i wouldn't
make as much as my wife as a first year
kindergarten teacher so i decided that i
could make a living in history but i
loved it i always researched that i was
in graduate school and i switched and
became a lawyer
in the course of law i
got involved in taxation
and i've been heavily involved in the
trenches for about 20 or 25 years and
i'm inclined to
agree with
i think it was the the greek historian
thucydides who said that no one should
write about war who'd not been a soldier
and i don't think anybody should write
about taxes
really who hasn't been in the trenches
if you've been in the trenches of war i
think you understand war
i think from a distance we get the wrong
impression of war and i think from a
distance
the academics uh and many of the tax
professionals don't know what it's like
in the trenches and i and i think i
brought together a love of history
on the one hand and my experience with
the tax world on the other and that gave
me a perspective
about the importance and the power of
taxes
and i think the power is a good word to
use because
people get mad about taxes
and you think we are mad about taxes you
should have seen our ancestors how mad
they were and i think that's the first
thing that surprised me in studying
taxes is how mad our ancestors were i
mean we started a revolution that and
but it was it was a mean revolution
people died
um the civil war as you might read in my
book i say it was started over taxes not
slavery
and a third of a million americans died
in that war
and and uh take the french revolution
now we know that was tax oriented we
know that the king of france and his
queen were beheaded what most people
don't know is that the people were so
mad that they gathered up all of the
chief tax people and they took him down
to the guillotine and they cut all their
heads off
they were mad about taxes
and and i think that it's a powerful
force and if you look at it as a force
for shaping history and for explaining
why people react the way they do
then he becomes a fascinating subject an
amazing subject of interest and
and and i wrote the book because i think
that our
i think our ancestors would speak to us
today
and they would point out to us
how foolish we are and and how wise we
should be if we'd listen to them in
terms of
how they suffered over the wrong kind of
taxation i mean empires have collapsed
over taxes
and there's a sense of viciousness that
developed throughout history uh
like in the french revolution when they
when they hauled down the tax people and
cut off their heads
how much tax do we pay today compared to
what the
ancestors forefathers did
i think we probably pay more i think the
systems are a little different but i
think we're a little more prosperous
than they were
but if you think in terms of percentages
um
then i think maybe we pay less
uh
let's go way back in history
uh one of the one of the great uh
celebrations or
if we recall it that is like hanukkah
for example it's a famous jewish holiday
that takes place at christmas time and i
tell my jewish friends that that really
the cleansing of the temple
and the candelabras was really a
sideshow what really what hanukkah was
about was a revolution and a revolt over
taxation
and the taxes that the jewish people had
to pay at that time to the greek was
one-third of all the crops
and that's gross
and fifty percent of all the vineyards
and all the orchards that's a heavy tax
and when the peace treaty was worked out
during that period in which what period
is that well we're talking about two to
three hundred bc
there's nothing in the treaty that would
allude to the hanukkah celebration what
the treaty says is that we won't have to
pay any more taxes
and and that was the great victory that
they they achieved in fighting the
greeks at that time
you say in your book about the
revolution american revolution
that
i mean a lot of people think it was over
tax and you say that we really weren't
that
excessively taxed by the british
no actually
um i say in the book if revolutions are
the consequence of oppressive taxation
then the american revolution should not
have existed
we were a very blessed people we had the
protection of the british nation they
had recently fought and and defeated the
french they'd opened up the western
frontier and all the british government
was asking for is that we pay some of
the cost of maintaining the troops that
were there in america defending us from
the french now that was reasonable
and
and
but the americans
they felt that they shouldn't be taxed
without their consent
and and consent to them
was different than the british felt now
the principle of consent was a british
idea
so the british parliament believed in
consent too
but they felt that parliament consented
on behalf of all the englishmen
everywhere
uh the women they couldn't vote but it
consented on behalf of the women for
they were taxpayers if they had private
estates there were also
british colonies around the world you
see and so parliament acted for all the
british people everywhere and hence it
acted for the americans
so that
why would the americans object if they
had to pay for some of the costs for
maintaining the armies that defended and
protected them
so really really it wasn't an oppressive
tax
the americans objected to the fact that
they didn't really consent to it that
consent had to be genuine and they
didn't have anybody that represented
them
and that was their main pitch what was
the boston tea party all about
well the boston tea party wasn't quite
the
honorable event that we say that it was
what happened is that the the british
government uh and we we might get a
little background on that uh the the
first revolt in the colonies was was the
the stamp act revolt and and
when the british government decided to
to levy stamp taxes it did it because
they were having revolts at home and and
what happened at home is that they had a
cider tax and
and the british people were revolted
over it in london and so the british
government said well let's try and get
the americans to pay some of the bill
and so let's let's make some stamp taxes
and so the stamp taxes were introduced
and there were revolts in the colonies
and franklin uh benjamin franklin he
went to uh to london and and he
complained he said now you can't tax us
uh internally
which the stamp tax was it was like an
excise tax but it's perfectly all right
to tax us externally like a customs a
duty
so the british government
eventually of course repealed the stamp
act and then they went ahead and
introduced duties
on the americans
and they said we're doing just what
benjamin franklin said would be
acceptable
well the americans
decided well we made a mistake
it wasn't that acceptable in fact the
british prime minister made a an
interesting comment he thought the
distinction between external taxes and
internal taxes what the americans made
such a big deal out was perfect nonsense
that's the words he used and he was
right it was perfect nonsense so the
british government turned around and
gave the americans the kind of tax they
said they wanted well of course the
americans with they really didn't want
any tax
uh
and and some of the some of the members
of the british government like edmund
burke for example he said the americans
won't pay the tax even though you think
they'll pay the tax even though franklin
said they'd pay it when when it comes
down to it they won't pay any taxes they
don't consent to
so with the boston tea party was a
situation in which uh
the british government uh was trying to
compete with smuggled dutch tea
and in dealing with the smuggled dutch
tea
they decided to reduce all the duties on
the tax that on the tea that came in to
the colonies from the east indies
and
the result was that the tax would then
compete with the dutch tax they then
would grant special favors to those
loyal merchants who would handle the
british tea
and the result was that the other
merchants in boston were pretty angry
about it they disguised themselves of
indians they went on the ships and they
threw all the tea in into the water
benjamin franklin thought it was
terrible he says we should that was a
wanton act of of thievery and
destruction of private property and we
should compensate those people
what did you think jumping way beyond
those years when george bush said read
my lips no new taxes
well i thought that he should have and i
think most people he should have stuck
with it and the reason i say that is
that
we've come to look upon campaign
promises as as well maybe they'll you
know maybe they'll do it maybe they
don't
but i think that
when it comes to taxes
people as i said get mad about taxes
people take taxes real serious
and and i made an analogy in my book
that uh
that there's a there's a there's a
contract or a covenant between the
people in their government sort of like
a marriage contract
and that
one of the one of the
conditions of the marriage between the
people and the government is that for
better for worst
uh
for richer for poorer
like like the wedding vow but there are
certain aspects of the relationship in a
marriage
which are not for better for worse
there's a certain sense of loyalty and
responsibility to your mind to your mate
that you should adhere to
and adultery for example is not
something that that is for better for
worst that's something that goes to the
heart of a marriage and i think that
when the government deals with taxes
it's dealing in that very primary area
that's what revolutions have been made
over and and so when george bush had no
new taxes
he was he was he was hitting at the
heart of the relationship of the state
to its people
and when he betrayed that uh he lost
them at one time frame would you
actually write the book this book
what say that in what time frame did you
actually write this book in other words
what years
oh it's 20 years i i started writing it
in 1972. 20 this book's been in the
making for 20. this book is about 20
years in the making how did you do it
then yeah if you started 20 years ago
how did you keep track
well it started out i didn't start off
to write that book i started out because
i became interested in taxes and i was
teaching a course of
world history to college students and i
noticed that taxes would continually
show up in history and so i began to
take a look to see
what meanings we could we could discover
and i went to one of the great libraries
like i went to ucla library
and and i couldn't find anything on the
subject i said i can't believe this
something so important is taxes and
there's probably nothing that's been
written
to show
the broad history of taxes and the
influence of taxes on people and and so
i i became fascinated with it i wrote
some magazine articles they were
published people people liked them
and i developed a kind of a
of almost like a geometrical theorem
that behind every event in history
there's a tax story
it may get lost in the drama of a great
event like the american civil war
but there is almost always a tax story
at work
molding and framing civilization
and sure enough it seemed to be true
i i study the russians and i maybe study
peter the great or i may study the
modern russian state under communism or
i might study the french and and every
and the bible the bible was full of tax
stories and i went to sunday school from
the time i was a toddler i even taught
sunday school i don't ever remember
learning of a tax story but the bible is
chock full of them
from the very beginning all the way up
to the very end our tax stories so uh
you i became fascinated with it and uh
they were they were
uh just amazing to me and and and maybe
because i was a tax professional i
became more sensitive to the issue what
do you mean by a tax professional well a
tax lawyer
and what kind of law what kind of tax
laws you practice and where were you
doing this well i practiced all over the
world uh i've been international and i
think that's helped me because i'm
familiar with the tax systems in canada
and in throughout europe and in asia so
having become an international lawyer i
could compare and have this horizontal
vision
of america and its tax system in
relationship to the other tax systems of
the world how long have you lived in
canada 20 years
so
this tax professional work that you did
and this book has all been written from
canada that's true and is it easy to
keep tabs in america while you're doing
this oh yes are you canadian citizen or
last year
when did you become a citizen oh 15
years ago
by the way brian mulroney at one point i
think was 15 popular yeah yeah yeah did
that have anything to do with tax
absolutely
absolutely but in fact that's that's a
good example of taxation by consent uh
there's a difference between the consent
of lobbying a tax law through the
legislature which brian rooney did
or lobbying a tax law through congress
and the consent which is what the people
themselves really believe and will
accept
we had in canada a value-added tax
forced on us against our popular will
when
about four years ago and what's that
mean a value-added tax is sort of like a
national sales tax but is rather
sophisticated but essentially it is a
national sales tax and what what's
happened in those four years then
in canada well we have the tax they
collect a lot of revenue but people hate
it people people hate it very much how
much give us an example
of
this book let me see this book is 29.95
here in the united states
if there was a value-added tax would
that book cost more yeah it would cost
uh eight percent more roughly and is
that put on at the cash register or
along the way that's along the way
but it will show up on the on the
sticker price
yeah it's a sense like an excise tax and
uh
and a good contrast is that just a year
ago in switzerland
uh they proposed the same kind of
attacks
that america has or that canada has that
is essentially a value-added tax it went
to the swiss voters and they defeated it
and that's that's a distinction that i
think we should make is the difference
between real consent and vicarious
concern let me interrupt just to tell
you that uh when paul kennedy the yale
professor who
wrote the
the the two books uh both on the current
one on the bestseller list about the
21st century was here a couple weeks ago
i asked him if he had to
advise his kids or 15 years old where to
live
in
the whole world
he said switzerland
and you write some special things and
hear about switzerland and
talk about the democracy in switzerland
compared to the democracy in the united
states is there a difference absolutely
dramatic difference switzerland has will
became so real democracy real democracy
about the fundamental most important
things of society taxes
the swiss government
from time to time tries to introduce new
taxes tries to raise the rates of taxes
and they almost always get turned down
and i asked a swiss uh lawyer some years
ago i said
uh this is when they had defeated an
attempt to raise the the taxes income
tax rates and he i said what's going to
happen now and he said well they're
going to have to live on the income that
we that they have just like the rest of
us so the swiss people will not
surrender to their representatives the
powered attacks and i think that's one
of the one of the great virtues of
switzerland is that one of the points
that i've discovered in the book and one
that i think the major points in terms
of constitutional structure is that
whenever the power to tax
and the power to spend
reside in the same political body
whether it's a congress or a president
or a dictator
the power to spend will always override
the powered attacks
and and if you look back at england and
britain and in its early days when
england was rising to be a superpower
you had this separation of powers
parliament could you look at tax but not
spend
the king could spend but not tax and
that made a balancing system we don't
have anybody who really puts the
taxpayer first
and and i and i refer in the book to
william gladstone who was the the great
british prime minister who served he
served off and on for about 50 years
and gladstone
explained it by butter and bread he said
that the problem you have
with governments is that and he's
talking about the parliament of england
at the time or the house of commons he
said
they lean toward the tax department
that butters their bread and not towards
the taxpayer who makes the butter and i
think that's the problem right today in
america people you know with the new
congress and
and with the new taxes
people people are suspicious they're not
so sure these guys are really going to
reduce the deficit uh and uh and then
maybe these taxes are basically going to
be used just to spend back to
switzerland yes
uh if there's six million people that
live there how does the country work who
runs it
well it's run by the
well as government as a has a
confederation a federal government and
it has what you'd call state governments
or the cantons but
the federal government
they don't have the power to tax
and even even the salaries now now
they can't raise their own salary you
remember the congress not too long or
grazed a salary in a big uproar
that goes to the voters when it comes to
monetary matters in switzerland it goes
to the voters they will not surrender
that to the government how often
well whenever whenever they want a new
revenue measure it's got to go to the
voters
so if they want to raise tax at all
they've got to have a referendum right
any other country in the world do this
in a sense america does on the local
level
think about your school bonds and your
ro and your road bonds things like that
local government in america
very often does not give the city
council or the county supervisors the
power to tax that goes to the people
does anything like this happen in canada
nowhere worse
or worse what about
other countries of europe
don't know
i don't know
countries of asia you say in here that
the legend that there's a super race in
asia
that
the four tigers and all that came out of
the last couple years is a misnomer yes
well
one of the problems we have in
understanding asia is that here were
five
incredibly poor and defeated countries
you know japan was was crippled
south korea was badly destroyed in the
war uh hong kong was
even had to import its water
here are these asian tigers as we call
them singapore
taiwan hong kong and they all are now
miracle economies
and the question is well why are they so
prosperous
how have they done so well even japan i
mean you know japan has done
extraordinary well
some of them practiced some socialism
for a while
uh
many of them had the government intrude
into businesses
but today the general philosophy in in
south korea and taiwan they've had
special commissions
they've said that the less government
intrusion into business the better
that business should be left alone the
taxes should be moderate that if people
can keep the benefits of their work in
labor they work harder so that the real
one common denominator of the success of
the five great
prosperous asian countries has been
moderation in taxation
singapore yes lee kuan yew is no longer
a prime minister but when he was people
would call him dictatorial you don't see
that yes
dictatorial in what way well
politically he may have been dictatorial
but tax wise he was moderate
you'll see you see you can have a
prosperous country without necessarily
having a democratic process
how did hong kong work six million
people
british still control it
don't they have the same tax system as
britain no
no not at all
how do they get the independence
well
well probably because of the american
revolution
because the one thing that the american
revolution
sold for the british empire is taxation
by consent of the locals
so that even though the american
revolution was a drastic solution to the
problem after the american revolution in
fact it's i think it's 1778
the the british government passed a
resolution saying that they would not
institute taxes in the colonial areas
without the consent of the people so
in hong kong for example you have a
legislative assembly which is the uh
composed by an electorate
and and they then select an
administrative council there's a
governor who sent out from britain but
he he's not a he's not a major player
and so they govern themselves they
establish their own taxes
so they're basically when it comes to
revenue completely independent of the
british government 125 million people in
japan you say the americans came there
after world war ii wrote the
constitution and set up
a high tax system
basically we took the internal revenue
code and we mirrored it
we said this is the law you're going to
adopt along with you know all the other
things that the occupying forces did so
the japanese adopted that they they
accepted
the amer american internal revenue code
then they immediately started riddling
it with holes
so they didn't particularly want to
offend the americans so they started
making all kinds of exemptions and and
tax write-offs and special reserves and
the result was that the heavy taxes that
were around the books weren't really in
reality
that they they they started bringing
down the taxes by essentially you know
riddling the tax code
in fact
there's um
one famous professor in uh
university of chicago law school
and he wrote an article not too long ago
and he recommended that we simply scrap
our internal revenue code and adopt the
japanese code lock stock and barrel
because he says they got a better tax
code it's much simpler it's created
tremendous prosperity
we need to create more capital in
america and so why don't we copy them
they copied us
in the way you build cars and things
like that if you and i lived in japan
how would our lives be different with
that tax system that they have well most
of people in japan don't even file tax
returns
so that's that's the first thing uh did
you write about the special accounts
yes what do you call them the postal
yeah
yeah the postal savings accounts how
does that work
well it's a
in japan you can you can set up sort of
like a postal savings account in which
you get interest
but you don't have to say you're the
owner
and there are more of those accounts in
japan than there are people living there
which means lots of people have many of
them but you don't have to put your name
on it so the government doesn't know who
owns these accounts
so are they taxed they're taxed now they
were but for many years they weren't
even taxed at all but now there's a 20
withholding tax but but
nobody
knows who owns the accounts and the
japanese people want it that way
i think it's kind of a check on the
government that if the government starts
to tax too much
everybody will just put all their money
in these accounts how much can you put
in there i don't think there's any limit
who holds the money
well they're postal savings you remember
years ago when we had postal saving
certificates
maybe that was before your time
when i was a young boy you could take
your money down to the post office and
you could buy a postal savings
certificate which was sort of like a
savings bond or a and and it would pay
you a two percent interest
so this is basically there's no names on
them and no one names them
but there's 20 withholding yes that's
new that's new
now another thing about japan and this
is something that i think is worth
uh thinking about is that japan
basically had a a tax-free capital gain
i mean there was a very modest amount of
money that was withheld on every stock
sale over the japanese stock exchange
but i'm talking about one or two percent
and that was just automatic when you
bought or sold stock they were withheld
now if you lost money you could file and
maybe get a refund but that was the tax
about three
four years ago
the japanese finally adopted an american
style capital gains tax 26 percent
three years for long-term capital gain
and shortly after that the japanese
stock market collapsed
i don't think that was a coincidence
you mean this big collapse was watched
came right out right after they went
from practically no capital gains to 26
tax which means you have to declare it
on your tax return and and that the the
the thrust of japanese tax reform today
is in the interest of simplicity
i i want to ask this almost sounds smart
if you are so right with all these
situations so far and all over the world
why doesn't somebody just
buy your book and go with it no i think
it'd be a good idea
i think we're profoundly ignorant about
taxes it's one of the reasons i think
why the book's important
if you were to read in tax literature
today and there's tons of it that comes
out you're not going to find hardly a a
word about history
we seem to be profoundly ignorant about
the role of taxes in history
and and we seem to be doing the things
that we shouldn't be doing and in fact
i've likened it unto
um
i have some friends that are heavy
smokers
and and they don't want to be reminded
about
the odds they don't want reminded about
cancer and about the various diseases
and shortening of life expectancy
i think we don't want to be reminded
about history
we think we can beat the odds like both
smokers we think we can tax heavily
and we can get away with it now it may
have crippled rome and may have crippled
imperial spain it may have brought down
the netherlands it may have
caused american civil war which i think
it did but i think we must think we can
beat the odds
go back to the civil war uh
what proof do you have the civil war
started over taxes instead of slavery
i think the proof is impressive and i
know that a lot of people really smile
when i say that
i think
i think on the eve of the civil war
slavery was never
more protected
than it was at that time i think that
the slavers in the south had won the
battle for slavery in 1860.
the uh yeah was a taxes whether in
slavery that caused the civil war
the supreme court had had handed down
the dred scott case which gave blanket
approval to slavery in the country
the
president united states who was abraham
lincoln
in his first inaugural address he said
he said he had no
inclination to interfere with taxes and
he said i quote from my speeches i have
repeated time and again i'm not going to
interfere with slavery i have no
inclination to do so personally
congress then passed a resolution which
was to be a constitutional amendment
protecting slavery in the southern
states they'd won the battle they hadn't
fired a shot
but he did say something else in his
inaugural address
he said
in the south you see it seceded this
thing they'd walked out formed their new
government down in richmond virginia
and he said if they don't want the males
that's fine we won't interfere with
their way of life that's okay
but
taxes
we will collect and except for that
there will be no invasion of the south
now then lincoln was also interviewed by
a british correspondent from the fraser
magazine
and this is a sort of like time magazine
or something would be
and in that magazine the
the writer said well he was really a
very impressive man and i really enjoyed
my meeting with him and he said there's
not going to be any war and he wouldn't
use any of his military forces on the
south except
to collect the taxes to recover any
forts that had been taken over like fort
sumter and but except for that there'd
be no war so what lincoln had done had
given the south and ultimatum of taxes
or war
and and the reason they succeeded
not just because they were a blundering
generation but because part of lincoln's
platform was not freeing the slaves not
in the slightest
but was to raise the tariff
so that the heavy taxes on goods coming
into america were 47 that was a very
high tax and that meant that the
southerners
would have to pay that if they were to
buy foreign goods and if they didn't pay
that they would then have to buy
northern goods that were now protected
and the prices were jacked up because
there was no competition
and they hated it and every time they
they they paid a tax
on goods they knew it was going to go up
to the north to the federal government
that was under control the republican
party
or if they bought goods from the north
they knew they were paying through the
nose sort of like opec
and when they withdrew the first thing
they did in their new constitution was
to make taxes low
and then the north saw the problem
you've got a chart here that
talks about presidents attorneys general
and
supreme court justices what's the point
of this chart
the point of that chart is to show that
up to the time of the civil war the
south dominated the federal government
president united states attorney general
supreme court justices speakers of the
house predominantly all came from the
south this was before 1860. this is
before 1860. when the war was over no
presidents
the few we got
came in because somebody died in office
very few attorney generals you can see
the numbers there
so the south was really defeated in
terms of having any voice in the federal
government
on the next page i'll drop the book so i
can look at it you have a quote
you write
find it here that's the next two pages
lincoln was the most powerful president
the united states has ever known
that's why did you say that
i said that because
of the way he exercised the power over
the dissidents in the war
i even said that the the russians could
refer to abraham lincoln to justify the
deporting of solzhenitsyn
solzhenitsyn was was
thrown out of the soviet union because
the soviet union has a law against
slander against the state
that's a crime that's what the kgb is
for
lincoln had one of the leaders of the
democratic party arrested in ohio which
was not a war zone tried before a
military court convicted of of
expressing treasonable sentiments
because he hated the war
they then deported him to the south he
fled to canada
and he would continue to be strong in
the democratic party and he had the 1864
convention brand the war failure lincoln
had people locked up he suspended habeas
corpus
and you have to understand that the
they didn't have an attitude like we
have today
um like in vietnam or even in the gulf
war
america was very intolerant of anybody
who wasn't supporting the war he was
sort of with us or against us so if you
expressed
disapproval of a war
are you in trouble
now now we we we print people today they
have freedom of expression but it's only
been
in the latter half of the 20th century
in world war one uh many people were
locked up for expressing treasonous
enemies by simply saying that they
thought that the war was wrong who are
your favorite leaders that you wrote
about in here over the years
leaders that dealt with tax the way you
think it ought to be dealt with
i'd have to say women
that might surprise you
i think that
the greatest monarch that england and
the europe has ever known as elizabeth
the first
she's my favorite she was remarkable
not only was she remarkable in the sense
that she captivated the men that were
very able men that served under and she
outwitted all of the rulers of europe
she
her tax system was called the miracle of
the age
just like we call the miracle economies
you know out in asia they call it
because she lowered taxes
how could she do that she came to power
from a father henry viii
almost like clinton he had deficits i
mean the british government was broke
england was a mediocre country
she ended
and britain was on the way to become a
superpower or england was at that time
she lowered taxes and yet she fought and
beat the spanish which is the most
powerful empire in the world
and she left with a very sizable
profitable treasury
why did she do it
one frugality
she said
that i will accept whatever my subjects
will give me and she operated an
extremely frugal government
and i think and that's key number one to
success that's what the romans had in
the early days of their greatness was a
very frugal government
she um she knows she lowered taxes
and she's the author of a statement that
it has never to my knowledge been
attributed to her
to love and to be taxed is not given to
man
now i've seen that recently in in
magazines in america and i and i've seen
it around the world
meaning that
you have to expect the fact that when
you tax the people going to hate you
that isn't what she
meant elizabeth said i will i will end
my reign as i began with the love of my
subjects
and what she meant by that is that she
wanted her subjects love
and consequently she would let them know
of her revenue needs but she would not
oppress them again her reign was what
years
uh would be in the 16th century
madison books yes who's that
that's a
trade book
of uh university press of america and
what's university press of america it's
probably the biggest academic press in
the united states what do they think of
this book
well they published it
what got them intrigued about the book
what made them think that this would
sell
um
i went down to talk to them about it
where are they they're in uh they're not
only about 50 miles superior lastly yes
they're down in land in
maryland and what year did you go to see
him
oh a couple years ago
and
they had reservations about it that you
know tax books are dull and i said well
this one isn't dull
i said taxes are are such a powerful
force in life there's no reason for
history attacks to be dull it should
probably be exciting i mean
um i think i mentioned uh well the
american revolution was was overtaxed
yes that war was overtaxed i said well
let's take the french revolution
uh you remember remember the guillotine
where the guillotine where they cut off
all the heads and i said everybody knows
they cut off the king's head and they
cut off the queen's head i bet did you
know that the french people gathered up
all the chief tax people and they herded
them down and they cut off the heads of
every single one of them they were mad
and and and that's that so
um all right they they decided to
publish a book
you write about israel yes
you say that
using uh feline terminology if the
foregoing asians are tigers meaning that
places like south korea and hong kong
then israel is a sick cat and
economically not in the big cat league
at all that's correct why
basically because heavy taxation
basically because they're a social
estate
they were founded by
east european jewish people who were
pretty well
persuaded by the importance of socialism
and even marxism
and
but their socialist economy is dragging
and yet they've had the love and the
devotion and the support of the jewish
people all over the world particularly
in america
you'd think they'd be the most
prosperous country in the world let me
read this
for the past decade the net immigration
of jews to israel jews to israel
is a minus
more jews are leaving israel than are
entering how come their population's
gone up to five million well
when i wrote that statement it was
before the influx of of the of the
russians
except for the russians who are making
refugees it will go anyplace they can go
the jewish people the more more
successful entrepreneurs and businessmen
are leaving israel israel's decline
begins with excessive dumb taxes
what kind of tax and they also later on
you say israel is a mess
yeah
what kind of dumb taxes do they have too
high
you just look at the numbers in there uh
they just they're just too they're
crippling taxation i can't give you the
numbers now but they're crippling
who's the
who's the greatest
taxer in history of american presidents
i guess we'd have to say roosevelt was
fdr yeah i think so yeah when did the
progressive texts when did withholdings
start in the united states they started
doing world war ii
but for what reason
government need the money withholding
sure and people like it no
see it used to be you filed your taxes
on april 15th and you paid them
the withholding tax gave the the
government the money early
well you know there's a time value to
money so with holy tax it creates more
money any other country in the world
withholding tax oh yeah everybody does
japan does
in fact in japan most people don't even
have to file returns taxes withheld
if you had to pick a country in the
world to go to besides canada or the
united states or maybe including canada
certainly including the united states
that has the best tax
environment is there a single country
you'd pick
probably hong kong
a second country
well any of the asian tigers i mean you
know i would they're all solid what
about the tax in switzerland is that
higher lowering even though they're
switzerland's fairly high tax country
most people don't realize that it's
fairly high tax they like it
well they like it but
switzerland has maintained very strong
military forces
every swiss citizen
is in the army
they
they spent a lot of money on national
defense
and and they felt that because they were
strong enough hitler uh decided that he
didn't want to invade them and so and
they have felt that their their military
forces are necessary just like america
does
in the
opening
they actually you actually call it
forward you have uh alvin
barbusca yeah senior fellow hoover
institution stanford university yeah how
come
you want to know the story of that sure
i i was doing research on israel on
modern israel and he and he is one of
the very famous
uh advisers to the israeli government
and i couldn't find one his latest books
now he's
at the university of toronto we have 17
books listed and but this one i couldn't
find it was a modern israel
so i called up the hoover institution to
see if they had it
and and they didn't have it and they
said well why don't you call mr bush get
home
so all right i'll call mr busquet home
and so i called him at home and i
proceeded to ask him about the book and
he told me about it and it was
and then he said he says are you the
adams that writes about taxes because i
had written a previous book what was the
name of your previous it was called
fight flight and fraud the story of
taxation what year 1970 1983
and he said that's the finest book about
taxes ever written in the english
language
and i unless you really believe that he
says i have two copies i said i've got a
new edition
of much more revised i said would you
write the forward he said i'd love to so
that's the story of the forward did he
tell you why it was the best book ever
written
no
he just said it was
and as he says in the forward there he
says he'd place it at the top of the
list of any any reading on the subject
of taxes so it's still pretty much the
same opinion have you ever advised any
american politicians on in their
political campaigns no
would you ever do that if i'd love to
who would who's your favorite do you
have a favorite right now that's out
there wanting to run for president well
i know my favorite would be david pryor
who's the democratic senator from
arkansas why
because he was the one that authored the
taxpayers bill of rights
and when he came up with it he couldn't
find anybody to co-sponsor it not even a
co-sponsor
and eventually it got on the bandwagon
and and it was adopted it's it's just a
step in the right direction now he wants
taxpayers bill the rights number two he
didn't go far enough did he get the
first one passed yes yes what'd he get
out of it well there are some benefits
but it but it doesn't get to the heart
of the problem
as you know toward the end of my book i
might make some pretty hard hitting
suggestions as to how to reform the
system
and uh
i think that that he just dealt with
some administrative abuses that were
i thought were needed correcting but
they didn't get the heart of the problem
where does he get his ideas you know
people i think from taxpayers i i think
that you know i used to one of my law
partners i said when i practiced the
united states was the congressman
and i was a junior junior member of the
firm and i used to have to read a lot of
letters that came in from constituents
he was a congressman when you worked
with him yeah he was a senior partner
what was his name charles teague
he died about uh
16 years ago california yes california
and while he was a congressman he also
practiced law well not really but he in
those days they associated with the law
firm so there was some practice he could
do yes and you had to read his mail
he would do his job
but nothing ever would come of it he
complained to the district director and
it just sort of gets left off and that
would be it and he'd do the best he
could but he didn't really have the
ability to act as a watchdog over his
people in his district and that's one of
the faders i think of the system
i think a congressman ought to be able
to look out for his constituents or you
know the members of his district
and and when the irs misbehaves i think
he ought to be able to have a little
clout he's our representative that's
what democracy is all about
who do you go to you go to your
representative and if he's powerless
then then the irs becomes a law unto
itself
there's no redress there's no checks and
balances and it's the lack of checks
that is the problem with the system
where were you born
uh salt lake city utah
did you grow up there no grew up in
southern california what'd your parents
do
my dad was in the cattle business
your mom
just a housewife i mean i said yes he
was a housewife
and
where did you first get your interest in
history
i got my interest in history my first
year of college and uh
at whittier college
and placed it uh president next year
absolutely yeah run president nixon
and i got permission to take a course in
russian history and far eastern history
and from then on i was hooked but i had
some wonderful teachers they just
absolutely inspired me anybody teach you
about tax no
not a word
you left there and went where you went
to ucla to do what to study law
nothing in between just bingo law degree
what year did you get out of law school
1953 then what
then i went up to ventura and i
practiced law in the firm that was
called teagan dixon
and mr t was a congressman that was the
junior member of the firm how long did
you stay there 10 years
then what
well in the course of that 10 years i
got interested in taxes
i didn't study tax in law school with
the idea of being a tax lawyer
the fact that i avoided taxi you know it
was
i wanted to to
vote you know do more interesting things
than tax
but the first case that i got when i
when i with the firm hired me when i was
waiting for the bar results they put a
file on my desk and they said we got a
tax problem solve it and of course since
i was a junior and hadn't even passed
the bar yet i i handled the case
and i apparently did a wonderful job and
from then on i was an expert
when you talk about being in the
trenches is that where it was well no
that's what started yeah
as the years went by i got more and more
involved with taxation
and um
one interesting story which might have
something to do with the book
my experience
with in the early days with the internal
revenue service was very positive
there were some
the agents in ventura were really
outstanding and the one fellow who there
was retiring and he got to know me and i
got to respect him
he told me on the eve of his retirement
he says now don't repeat this but he
said
the new agents that are coming out from
washington are being taught to harass
and intimidate taxpayers and he said you
know it never used to be that way
and he says you lawyers ought to do
something about it because if you can't
nobody can
but he says
don't quote me because i'm going to
retire
now that was
quite a bit of information to pass on to
me but i always kept that within me and
i said well maybe someday i can do
something about it and i think that book
is doing something about it
you met your wife somewhere in this
process and moved to canada where was
that i met her in california she was a
young widow and i
she had a russian restaurant and
she's a russian and she took him back to
russia
and
and
she took back to canada and it was
during the vietnam period and i enjoyed
canada
and so i thought i'd do something
different so i decided to live in canada
did you ever live in russia
no we visited it a few times you know
see her family and so forth how did she
get over here in the first place
she was one of those unfortunate young
children young girls um who was trapped
in the german zone and it was shipped to
germany to ship to work in the labor
camps so when she was 13 years old she
left russia never saw her mother again
and was was in a german labor camp
she had the good fortune of being freed
in the in the american zone
now when you look at what's going on in
russia right now with the whole up evil
tax have anything to do with it
well in a sense tax has everything into
it in a sense
because communism is the ultimate form
of taxation
and you see
what happened to the russians and the
russians have been
maybe their great mission in the world
has been to protect the west because
they had communism which was a western
idea that was you know given birth in
germany in england where marx was and
his followers they had it forced on them
against the popular
will and they lived under that system
and they suffered
and and they can show to the world where
the terrible calamity that enforced
system is so maybe sacrifice in the name
of the world has been the russians great
mission so the chaos that's in russia
today is because of living under the
ultimate form of taxation from each
according to his ability and to each
according to his need that's the maximum
that's progressive taxation in its
ultimate form
from each
you say that john stuart mill of brit
invented this whole idea that slavery
uh was a reason for the civil war how'd
he do it well he just believed he
popularized the idea in this country
well yes in this country too so because
because he was very very famous
so while he wrote for the fraser
magazine many of his articles were
published over in the site
and and he was a very very famous writer
brilliant writer you know what his his
writings today are still published and
he said taxes was or not taxes but
slavery was the cause of civil war
you uh in the back almost near the end
of the book have the laffer the famous
laffer curve what is it
well the laffer curve and i've added a
little bit of my own to it like the
negative and the positive the laffer
curve
says that
when you when you start having a tax
you get to the point as the curve swings
up where
you reach the maximum amount of revenue
that you will collect and that
thereafter if you keep raising the rates
you get less and less and less
so when you tax it 100 you get nothing
now laffer developed this from
from statistics and and the one most
interesting statistics
is in the book there is that the first
income tax was very mildly progressive
in 1916 and the rate was seven percent
at the top bracket
five years later the top bracket was 77
percent
in 1916 there were about 220 people that
reported a million dollars worth of
income
in
1921 five years later there were only 20
people about the reported
a million dollars worth of income so
that nine out of every 10 million dollar
earners disappeared
now the statistics which you show do
deal with a little lower level with the
300 dollar level and what you had is
that during that same period
if you were made more than three hundred
thousand dollars that four out of every
five taxpayers just disappeared so the
more you tax the less you get
was mr laffer successful and who is he
by the way he was a economist at the
university of southern california do you
know him no
do you think his idea that was adopted
by president reagan was successful yes
how come we're four trillion dollars in
debt well because they spent too much
but they raised a lot of money and the
revenues went up
it's just you see that's the problem the
power to spend the power to tax even
though we lowered
lower taxes revenues went up but they
spent just went higher they just can't
control their spending appetites
what's your favorite chapter in here
that's an interesting one
i think maybe my favorite chapter
is the one on the enlightenment based on
the old navy expression no one got the
word
you know that's an old navy expression
no one got the word
and during the enlightenment which was
the ideas that were the founding of the
united states and the founding of even
the modern world
they had the word on taxation they were
very bright guys about it and and i
listed the points that they raised and i
and i think we've lost sight of those
things
and they say look
look what you're doing
and you're crazy
how many printings have you had on this
book so far uh they're on the second one
now how many books are out there
well the first one sold out in our three
weeks
and uh the second printing will be 5 000
copies would you how many depend on the
first one ten no no they only fitted
seventeen hundred see they had their
doubts
but things are
moving yeah they only sold out in three
weeks
what's that we got about a half a minute
what's the best thing that people will
say about this book in 10 years if it's
been successful as far as you're
concerned
it it
made taxes the people's business again
tried to make taxes understandable
and something that the people can become
involved in charles adams author of for
good and evil the impact of taxes
underlined on the course of civilization
we thank you for joining us thank you
[Music]
charles adams is a taxation law
specialist and an independent scholar
for the cato institute a think tank in
washington dc
his book for good and evil the impact of
taxes on the course of civilization is
published by madison books and for more
information visit their website at roman
littlefield.com
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore presentation of c-span's book